Welcome back everyone this will be my video for
that new spider-man no way home green goblin
first look that just released there was also
a leaked trailer that just dropped in the last
couple of days you may have seen in your feeds all
addressed that too yes it was an actual trailer
people are always confused when leaks drop
because sometimes they're just fan creations
this time it was an actual leaked trailer
i'll talk about the green goblin first look
first then i'll talk about the leaked trailer
footage if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos quick shout out
to my friends at verizon amc plus who asked to
sponsor this video they're hosting the first ever
the walking dead digital autograph signing today
with actors like norman reedus you can register
for an opportunity to get a free limited edition
walking dead digital autograph card there'll
be autographs from daryl dixon himself the
other actors like maggie played by lauren cohan
carol played by melissa mcbride and jerry played
by cooper andrews this week each day you'll
be able to sign up to win so i'll put a link
in the description for their website so you can
check that out so recently in the past few days
you may have seen a ton of posts featuring
the new green goblin all over your feeds
we saw the classic pumpkin bombs from the toby
maguire spider-man movies in that last spider-man
no way home trailer and the willem dafoe green
goblin laugh is very iconic at the time most of
us assumed that meant that he would be in the
movie in some way in the reason why they just
didn't show him on screen was because it was one
of the few things that had not leaked out and the
whole reason why they gave us that alfred molina
dr octopus scene was because he himself literally
revealed that he was in the movie like no i'm
definitely in it much to kevin feige chagrin
but the whole idea was that he was from the same
alternate universe as dr octopus and had long
since died when dr octopus showed up in spider-man
2. so there were just a lot of questions about
what was going on with green goblin in the movie
i will explain how it's possible for dr strange's
spell to effectively bring him back to life even
though it only seems like it's bringing him back
to life that's not exactly what doctor strange's
spell is doing it's all about the new rules of
how the multiverse and different timelines
work that marvel's using for the mcu but if
you watch the loki series you already have all the
information you need to understand how that works
the actual confirmation on willem dafoe's green
goblin and his look comes from a couple different
people inadvertently working together without
actually working together it all started a little
while ago with a reddit post from an administrator
of one of the subreddits explaining what some of
the returning characters like green goblin toby
mcguire andrew garfield were supposed to look like
during the movie when they appear then separately
another totally unrelated artist revealed the
actual look with some concept art and you can see
he's actually got the same vibe as alfred molina's
doctor octopus both of them have the exact same
basic costume from their tobey maguire spider-man
movies with a few minor additions like there was
a new preview of dr octopus where it looks like
he actually has iron man tech integrated with
his octopus arms don't worry i'll explain that
in a separate video that's like a whole different
thing because long time fans who've been following
the movie news for years and years now might
remember that they originally wanted to tie
iron man's origin in the first iron man movie
to doctor octopus and have him be the one to
have created dr octopus's arms but way back when
they made that first iron man movie in 2008 sony
wasn't so keen to work with them on stuff like
this so they basically had to remove that aspect
out of the story but this is what green goblin
is supposed to look like at least later in the
movie because dr strange's spell is grabbing
them all from moments right before their deaths
so it's the same basic green goblin armor
that he wore during the first tobey maguire
spider-man movie and you notice he's repaired
a lot of the damage to his green goblin suit
from their final fight what it seems like they've
done here is at some point in the movie he repairs
most of the damage to his suit like you see these
extra metal yellow pieces and tech on top of his
old green goblin suit he also adds a very comic
book accurate green goblin strap to hold his
pumpkin bombs and other gear fans of the classic
spider-man comics will probably recognize some of
these easter eggs a little bit easier like why is
he riding around with a strap doesn't he have all
this technology well it's because that's the way
he did it in the original comics the whole idea
was some of the minor changes they're making to
some of these sinister six characters like jamie
foxx's electro and giving him yellow lightning
is to make them more accurate to the classic
versions of the sinister six characters also big
deal here he's not wearing the helmet he's got
these goggles the goggles almost look exactly
like dr octopus's goggles from spider-man 2.
but there's no helmet in sight so either it's
destroyed or he's just not using it during the
movie and i think that's actually kind of cool
because now you can see his face during fight
scenes and part of the whole brilliance of
willem dafoe's green goblin performance was
the way he would flip from norman osborn to green
goblin on a dime like the scenes of him talking
to himself in the mirror and you don't really get
that when he's wearing the helmet so taking the
helmet away just gives willem dafoe more room
to actually act this is a clip of him talking
about that he actually really loved playing green
goblin and norman osborn i loved in spider-man
particularly playing the double roll everybody
thinks about the green goblin and that was fun
but the more interesting role was probably the
father because norman osborne because you could
play these scenes where it would switch from
comedy to drama in a line uh i think of the
scene where um they have like a thanksgiving
dinner there we are looks delicious norman
will you do the honors
there's a couple of things that still make
me laugh because they're so double-edged and
they go back and forth between being really heavy
and really kind of silly if you remember a couple
months ago people were asking him about being
in the movie too and he said i prefer to let the
work speak for itself you know when that comes
out it'll come out people will see what happens
it was his way of talking around the question
without trying to confirm or deny anything
like we know what's up we know you're going to
be in there somewhere but based on these multiple
different sources it does seem like the pumpkin
bombs in the trailer the trademark laughter
are not just smoke and mirrors there's still a
version of mysterio out there whether you think
the quentin beck mysterio somehow faked his death
there's still a lot of theories about that or it's
william guinta riva pretending to be the second
version of mysterio because he has all mysterio's
technology during that scene of dr octopus
fighting spider-man in the iron spider suit on the
george washington bridge a lot of people wondered
if there was some smoke and mirrors going on and
it was just dr octopus fighting spider-man
or if willem dafoe's green goblin was also
part of this fight and they were just editing
the trailer to mess with your heads marvel does
that all the time even though technically sony
are the people releasing the spider-man trailers
but regardless of who else is in this particular
bridge fight scene it does seem like willem dafoe
himself is in the movie as this more comic
book accurate looking version of his green
goblin from the toby maguire spider-man movies
the whole reason he can be alive now in present
day when we saw him die there was a funeral they
clearly implied in the tobey maguire spider-man 2
in spider-man 3 movies that he died harry osborn
even took up the mantle briefly in spider-man 3.
it's all because when doctor strange weaves his
spell to make people forget that spider-man is
peter parker the spell is so powerful that it's
like getting rid of a spider in your house by
having a contractor come in and replace most of
your house with totally different materials it's
meant to be big time overkill which is how they're
justifying all the craziness with the sinister six
characters from the other universes he thinks that
doctor strange is fixing his problem by replacing
people's memories with bits of alternate timelines
and universes but really it just makes things
worse everyone he's ever loved or ever met the
avengers everybody forgets about him and benedict
cumberbatch basically confirmed that during the
movie spider-man goes off the rails again trying
to undo what they just did that's kind of what's
going on with all the scenes of spider-man versus
doctor strange in the trailer like it's not an
evil version of doctor strange that spider-man is
trying to stop it's a local man ruins everything
situation but spider-man making it worse
and doctor strange trying to be kind of apparent
to him disciplining him to keep him from doing
something that will make everything even worse
talking about that leaked trailer footage that you
may have seen recently in your feeds before sony
took it down the past couple of days there was an
actual new version of the trailer that leaked
out it was about 40 seconds long and featured
a bunch of new scenes most of them had unfinished
special effects but it was an actual trailer one
of the new scenes was of doctor strange's cloak of
levitation grabbing spider-man mid-air during one
of their scenes when they were going up against
each other wrapping itself around him to just
stop him most of you probably see where i'm going
with this if you watched marvel's what if series
where spider-man got the cloak of levitation it's
literally exactly like that but in live action
the reason why he gets the cloak is just a
little bit different but the effect is the same
call him doctor mr spider-man strange spider-man
in spider-man no way home you could make the
comparison to avengers infinity war with the way
dr strange used the cloak of levitation against
thanos so during their big fight on titan doctor
strange told the cloak to stop thanos from closing
his fist so that he couldn't use the infinity
gauntlet this time it's more like the cloak is
grabbing spider-man to stop him while he's in
the middle of the air between two high-rises
i can't put the clip in my video here for obvious
reasons because sony would take the video down
but we'll probably see the full version of that
late trailer relatively soon you may have seen
that the next major spider-man no way home trailer
really isn't supposed to be released for more than
a couple weeks marvel is doing their big disney
plus day comic con event and that's gonna be like
trailer city with a ton of new footage for all the
marvel disney plus series in the star wars series
we'll get a ton of the tv show trailers during
that of course i'll do videos for all those but
sony will probably wait till right after that like
the week after maybe a little bit later to release
that next big spider-man trailer but whenever
they do release it of course i'll do a video for
it there's supposed to be a new morbius trailer
probably with a bunch more spider-man easter eggs
this tuesday so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel to be the first to watch that
don't think the sony people forgot that morbius
was coming out that's still coming out in january
and that'll answer a little bit more about
this whole multiverse crossover on top of
what happened during the venom let there be
carnage post-credit scene everyone post all
your reactions in the comments below what do you
think about this new look for the green goblin
i just did a video for that early marvel what
if season 2 teaser trailer you can click here
for that and click here for my breakdown of the
new spider-man no way home sinister 6 preview
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!